[Music]
you have no idea what's coming
mr. wit broke the rules
I trust you understand the repercussions
if he survives you shouldn't be here
nice suit good to see you too I need
your help after this we are less than
even
there's no escape for you the high table
wants your life
would you help set the mood frown you
guessed
let us begin our services still
off-limits to me what do you need
guns lots of guns you think you can take
John wick
you got a nasty surprise coming
I've been looking forward to meeting you
for a long time and so far you haven't
disappointed
we can keep this up as long as you'd
like
but this only ends one way
[Music]
all of this for what because of a puppy
was it just a puppy
you do realize that I'm management
now right I'm not service anymore John
so I don't go around shooting people in
the head I'm not asking you to kill
anyone I just need you to get me to her
to who your old boss
you want to kill Brad I'm not gonna kill
him I just need to talk what could he
possibly give to you guidance look I
made a deal when I agreed to run this
hotel and that deal said that I had to
follow the rules at the table if you're
not gonna kill him he is gonna kill you
and then probably me too for walking you
up in there even if I wanted to I can't
help you Johnny
the high table wants your life how can
you fight the wind
how can you smash the mountain how can
you bury the ocean how can you escape
from the light of course you can go to
the dark but they're in the dark too so
tell me Charlie
what do you really want
New York Public Library
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
change of plan
the Continental can you see that he's
received by the concierge
yes sir mr. Wayne
good job
in the John wick universe each of the
major cities are under oath has a
Continental Hotel a place of refuge we
can have that moment of calm before you
have to step back out on the streets and
defend yourself rules without them we
live with the animals the world of the
Continental is more explored this time
we always joke that in the first movie
we had a lobby in a room a second one
you got to have a few more rooms and now
the third one we have the Continental
it's fun to just go bigger and bolder
each one of them increase the amount of
world building on a really unique and
interesting level the both coins the
speakeasy
what can we infuse into each film mr.
wick broke the rules
I trust you understand the repercussions
John breaks one of the most hard and
fast rules and the Continental all his
privileges have been revoked there's
nowhere to hide my table once your life
there's no escape mister this
[Music]
cinema is rich in traditions what has
come before I saw Fisher called
villainous and it turned out that
shattered senior villainous was a great
action movie and had a great motorcycle
sequence in it the first couple of times
we watched it me and my stunt team I VFX
scene or impress oh god that was a
really cool idea this is tipping our hat
to them here's our little ode to you
good [ __ ] job we said such higher
standards on the first two movies that
you always have to kind of one-up with
we got to put things on the edge of
what's real and still make it cinematic
they designed this motorcycle sequence
which was new for us we have a bike
chase between shut down the Verrazano
Bridge for it's like dance choreography
there's movements there's a language of
movement that you have to play too
so it's motorcycles with swords
Jonathan what have you done
[Music]
Todd
there's no escape for you the high table
wants your life
tell me what you want person I can't
help you to reach the unreached
you expecting to meet you doubt a 40
million dollar bounty on his head
everyone the city owns a piece of it I
say the author about evil dark - five
seconds Charlie text comunicados in
effect in three two
and away we go
[Music]
[Music]
Sophia we're not going in like the old
days just the conversation nothing's
ever just a conversation with you John
[Music]
[Music]
I went into the training at least five
months before the physicality the
martial arts and then the weapon work
all the time that have put in I'm just
better at it
Gianna's trains his ass off when we
train him will go for hours and hours
hours and he just won't stop it's
amazing it really was one of the hardest
training I've done because there's a lot
more action in Parabellum than there is
in the other two films he trains for
months he does his own action he is the
most committed person that I've ever
worked with he does 98% of everything
you see on screen
some people say they want to do John
wick training and then it starts and
then they're like oh this is jolly and
when Holly said she wanted to do that
Chad said here you go and Halle said
thank you sir can I please have some
water I'll be the hardest six seven
months I think I've experienced in my
professional life I kept going cuz I
would just not quit the best way to fake
being good is just to be good and that
takes sweat blood and tears it's a level
of commitment that is not normal you can
say it I've been doing it I had to learn
to fight one leg piano and I had to
learn to fight with him in very close
proximity they're very much a team this
is just hardest [ __ ] but it's also a lot
of fun and I have a great team of people
that are teaching me in training
[Music]